[Music]
david is with us david is in louisville
kentucky hi david how are you
i'm doing well and uh thanks for taking
my call dave and george i appreciate
your guys's wisdom and opinion so i'll
try to be brief and
a little groundwork i'm an over-the-road
truck driver i am out five days at a
time and i have rotating weekends my
wife works full-time uh i would say two
full-time jobs she also takes care of
our kids all week while i'm gone um so
we have a 20 month old and we have a
second baby boy coming in nine days wow
so yeah mama's got her hands full um i
try to help while i'm there and this job
does have predictable schedules uh which
really helped a lot but here's what
happened uh
a lot of relational stuff and a little
financial thing but i i do wonder your
thoughts on the financial thing so
when we put the second car seat in the
uh she had a small suv
i was the one who said you know this
thing's a little tighter than it needs
to be in here for you having to pack
them out in and out all day by yourself
we might look at some other options
so we talked about it could not agree on
makes models anything i'm looking at
many vans she's looking at suvs
we actually went and physically looked
at some cars just to get some ideas uh
try to compromise on things
and there was a little compromise on
cars you know different makes and models
and then we were trying to figure out
what would be realistic in our range
with the trade and all that and
there were several we both got a little
uh sticker
eyeballs there and then tried to back
away from that
and there were several talks about you
know we're not going to finance anything
different than where we are now
to get into the vehicle we need to be
you know a lateral move is fine but
we're not going to go backwards
next thing i know saturday she sends me
pictures of this van that she just went
and picked up
and
financed 10 grand
we owed five as it was on the corner and
we had the money to pay it off we were
doing the stork mode thing
and i don't know
i don't know if she just
had a change of heart we had a
commitment conversation last night and
we agreed there's a lot of individual
and relational counseling needed to
figure out how we even got to where we
thought this was a good idea
my thought on the financial side is we
turn right back around and sell that van
and whatever the gap money is
between the sale and paying off the loan
that's what we go by um
she seems to still think i don't know at
what level that this was a good idea and
that we should keep it
that it's just five grand further
backwards
um and that we can we can pay it off if
we buckle down so i'm curious what your
thought is there
wow
um
well i'm vacillating between this lady
is completely overwhelmed with two
little uh babies she's pregnant
and and the fact that she completely
lost her dadgum mind
and went again and and went against
everything in the relationship lied to
her husband and acted like she wasn't
even married
um so i mean part of me simply
sympathetic to where she is and how
overwhelmed she is and i get all of that
but part of me is really ticked at her
right now
and i suppose and i suppose you're
probably 10x of both of those
exactly and and i do understand on the
one hand
and
not necessarily even my bigger vehicle
is the right choice of vehicle the loan
is completely separate from that
well in the does but this decision
making process that is completely out of
control
you're not going to ever have anything
financially
until we solve whatever is broken there
in her
uh in her mind on how relationships work
um so
i i um
uh uh
yeah financially what you need to do
sell the car
and you need to get a car that you can
afford
um and also that would probably be a
good idea for her to
do
to recommit to your marriage not
necessarily to the ramsey steps or
something you guys may decide together
that you want to go deeply in debt if
you want to do that that's fine but
whatever the first thing that has to
happen is you all have to get on the
same page and agree to keep your word to
each other
you just can't have a relationship where
you just
don't keep your word to each other or
where you act independently unilaterally
of each other like this
there's there's just no data that says
that creates a quality relationship yeah
the financial piece can be undone today
but the
relational piece the trust that's going
to take a while to build back up and i
think you're right that counseling is in
order and on the financial side do you
guys still have other types of debt
outside of this car loan yeah
how much how much a little bit yeah
they're working we're working baby step
two we're close we had yeah we had five
grand left on the cars this current car
is now ten so an additional five or six
um she has a
17 000 student loan which would have
been the next thing we tackled and then
some petty collections that she has from
old credit cards yeah
uh my guess is my guess is your wife
feels like that she's been running her
life by herself already for a long time
because you're just never there
and um she feels abandoned and she just
had to do what she had to do as an
abandoned single mom i'm thinking that's
where she is emotionally
you don't feel like that's where she is
but i think that's where she thinks she
is
i agree with that that that that's
probably pretty fair for how she feels
emotionally i guess my
concern is you know i don't downplay
that at all but
at least relationally and financially
we've agreed to be on the same page and
then you went and did yeah i mean i i i
i'm i'm livid of her breaking her word
and and just doing this but i'm trying
to figure out what level of
distress she must have been in to do
that because it sounds like you all had
very clear conversations and then she
just went and did whatever the flip she
wanted to do anyway so which just tells
me she's just in freak out mode
i guess
i mean because i i don't this lady does
not sound like someone who is
obstinate arrogant
she doesn't sound like that person to me
she sounds more like somebody who feels
i think she's a cornered animal and she
bit you
you know what i'm saying
yeah that's how it feels so you got to
get to the bottom of that before you can
fix this van thing the van problem is
that is the symptom it's not the thing
so
and it may be dude you're coming off the
road and you got little babies
and she she's overwhelmed
and you may be coming off the road and
doing something else so that you can be
there for your family for a season
i don't know but i i do know you need to
sit down the marriage counselor for sure
i'm not qualified to unravel all this i
can just i can kind of get on her side
for a minute but there's no way to
justify what she did on the other hand
so i can get on your side and be pissed
about it too i get it i understand where
your head is but i'm trying to figure
out what caused this so it doesn't
happen again
that's the thing because if you don't
break this you're gonna be broke your
whole life
so yeah sit down with a good marriage
counselor my friend so a couple days ago
george and i took a call from an
over-the-road truck driver
who's uh he had been talking with his
wife about trading cars
and uh without talking to him she went
and traded cars and went further into
debt he was pretty irate about that
um because they didn't we're not in
agreement about that and she just went
and did whatever she wanted to do
and uh we talked to him for a few
minutes the more we talked to him the
more if you go back and listen to the
call
uh the more we were questioning what's
really going on because he was like he
set her up threw under the bus pretty
much and then we're like yeah i think
you probably you're over the road she's
pregnant she's got a baby doing nine
days
and
you probably there's something else
going on here you read between the lines
i actually said you may need to come off
the road and take care of your family
and you guys need to get in marriage
counseling so um she apparently was
listening
or went back and listened to the call
and disagreed with a whole bunch of her
uh the things her husband said about her
uh and the conclusions we came to about
her as a result uh and so forth so send
us a long email
uh and and so we thought it'd be fun to
kind of go back through that because
it's really interesting so here's the
deal um well let's just say okay i
listened yesterday got to hear the call
you took from my husband regarding the
purchase of a van resulted in financing
10k i know responding probably won't get
air time to resolve the plethora of
issues you two seem to pick up on but i
felt at least i could provide some
context for my actions that would
hopefully lead to a rebranding of my
sanity because i said she may have lost
her dad got mine
and accountability for the situation the
truth is partially as you put it i was
backed into a corner and i bit back
so it sounded like they couldn't come
into agreement and he's on the road left
her you know stranded with a bunch of
kids and she just did whatever she
wanted to do kind of thing that's was my
point and so um
then she goes on for about
a page and a half explaining why it's
okay to borrow money to buy a van and
all this stuff which of course is not
true
uh my husband didn't mention that he's
packed all of his things and moved out
that's true he did not mention that and
has taken half of our emergency fund
with him
about nine days before i deliver our
second child oh really that's just nice
no he didn't mention that because i
probably would have ripped him a new one
for doing that it's like if you're gonna
leave you don't leave nine days before
baby comes dube
uh you know this didn't just suddenly
happen so yeah we would have um george
and i would have teed off on him on that
me more than george but because george
is generally nice
uh she closes with i'm not stupid i've
not lost my mind but backed into a
corner with no other resources or
choices i think i can own this one and
that's after rationalizing again for
five paragraphs that buying the van was
a good idea so let's go back and
re-regroup on this whole thing for a
little bit um number one
i don't like it
when any of you
none of us at ramsay like it when you
take our good common sense advice that
is meant for you to prosper in your
family and you weaponize it to use it on
your family or weaponize it to use it on
your spouse there's a thing in here
where he says
she says
he he refused any car i looked at
because he and he said dave always says
if the answer is no we don't do anything
if the answer if we can't come into
agreement the answer is no well that's a
general principle yes but what's going
on here is
you two are a hot mess
that's what's really going on here
both of you jessica you with your
rationalization
which i completely understand how you
get there in the middle of him being a
control freak and you getting ready to
have a baby and i get all of that but
you rationalized your butt off girl i
mean it's ridiculous and and him with
his lying to us and weaponizing
advice that we give here and using it to
verbally thrash his wife with
um you you guys desperately needed
marriage counseling a long time ago
long time ago
uh long before he calls on this radio
show
and uh we certainly did not tell him to
pack up his stuff and move on and it
sounds like he did that you go back and
listen to the call nowhere did we even
intimate that he should do that we did
tell him you guys need marriage
counseling and baby doll you did need
marriage counsel you do need marriage
counseling it's
you guys are a hot mess you you you bow
up and just go do whatever the crap you
want to do and go deeply in debt and buy
a van that you shouldn't have
against his wishes which indicates that
you guys are not on the same page and
have serious marriage problems and he's
being a twerp and a control freak and
not coming up with some way to take care
of his pregnant wife and kids and get
her into a car that works well to that
end everybody wants what they want
instead of being instead of serving each
other in this marriage she says to quote
him i don't care if it has a welded
five-gallon bucket for the front seat
you'll drive what i pick or i won't
agree to it because dave says if you
can't agree you go with who says no
that is not that is never come out of
here i mean we don't that's just that's
just completely weaponizing the advice
here
so yeah jessica you have a mess your
husband is a mess you're in a mess and
you did a stupid thing in the middle of
all that and it hurt to have her laundry
aired out you know on national radio
well i don't blame her for that too and
i'll pick on ladies getting ready to
have a baby in nine days oh my gosh
so uh but the point is
guys this is
if you can't get together on what to do
with money it's not a money problem if
you can't get together on what to do
with your car it's not a car problem
that's a marriage problem and it's
usually a selfishness problem i mean she
was selfish because she just went did
whatever she wanted to do he was selfish
because he's like i'm not going to agree
to anything because i don't like it and
i'm on the road and i'm going to hold
all the power like he has any power
which apparently he didn't so
uh you know it was just out of control
so the the inverse of this is
hey i love my wife and i understand
she's freaking out i got to figure out
some way to get her in a different car
that is good for our future and going
further in debt is not good for our
future
instead of i'm going to tell you what to
do and dave ramsey oh my god you twerp
and they they mentioned we didn't ask
their income they make 137 000
yeah and it paid off a bunch of debt
right yeah how much was it it was a lot
uh fifty thousand dollars in 15 months
they paid off she says
so um
uh what but you didn't ask what we made
she said well i didn't ask what you made
because that wasn't the question the
question wasn't it's not an income it
wasn't a math problem it was my wife
bought a car that we didn't agree to
problem
that was the call it wasn't like how
much money you make how much money you
make doesn't solve you know youtube not
getting along
so you can make 237 000 and still not
you still shouldn't go do that and he
still shouldn't put you in a position
that you felt like that was the only
thing you could do
so you two are being you're hot mess
you're a hot mess and you need to be in
marriage counseling both of you
bad
and so because here's the thing
sharon ramsey goes and does that
i'm gonna have a problem but i'm also
not gonna put her in a position that she
feels like that's her only way and if
she feels like that's her only way then
she's got a serious cinderella syndrome
like she deserves entitled and i'm
arrogant and whatever then we got
another issue going on and we're going
to be sitting down with with a
professional and helping us guide
through our relationship because
apparently we can't guide through it
ourselves and we've done that 10 years
you know after we were married about 10
years we about killed each other that
year
and so we you know marriage counselor
saved our lives and our marriage
saved my life because she probably would
have killed me in my sleep but um
but the uh uh i mean you know and so i
can i distinctly remember driving the
crappy
you remember this is how bad it was you
probably seen these on the road they're
still out there the two-tone blue astro
vans oh yeah you remember those yeah
those are real ugly this is like the
minivan of minivans
and it had like a bazillion miles on it
and i fried the transmission out of it
pulling the boat because it wasn't
designed to pull a boat it was a
lightweight little thing
and i put a new transmission in it and
this thing i mean it's stunk it had
cheerios like neck deep in it although
it was we raised little babies in it and
dogs and it was a mess
and she was over this fan
and
rightly so it was a piece of crap and we
were starting to make a little money we
finally got a little bit of money and
she's like i want to get a suburban i
want to get an suv like that's twenty
thousand dollars might as well be that
gum two hundred thousand dollars what do
you mean well you got twenty thousand
dollars coming in down there at your
company our company you keep telling me
it's mine i want some of the money out
there by suv i'm like yeah but that
twenty thousand dollars we can use to
invest in this thing we're working on
and it's gonna make us a hundred
thousand if we buy this car for twenty
thousand and we went back and forth and
went
and we just we kept arguing about
finally i had this moment where i went
you know what it's not an either or it's
a win
and i said so okay we're gonna we need
to do the investment of the company and
we need to buy the car
and which one which one we do first
which one we do first is the only thing
that mattered and so we just put her
first she won
there we go and you know what when she
won i won boom isn't that interesting
here's the takeaway from this story dave
they've got a child on the way and right
now they're both being children we need
less children in this family
how's that
now you'll get another email george uh
oh yeah you changed her brand
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey chef